What you're looking at is an MPC 3000. It
sits in a room amongst the most iconic
relics of our country's musical history,
and that room is on the fourth floor of
the National Museum of African-American
History in our nation's capitol. that MPC
was owned by J Dilla, who composed some
of the most revered beats in hip-hop
history. Technology has just taken a
giant leap forward. Hello I'm Roger Linn,
and this is the MPC 60 MIDI production
Center created by myself and Akai
professional. The MPC is this compact
machine that's a holding station for all
types of samples which you can play with
16 touch sensitive pads. The very first
model shipped in 1988 for just a few
thousand dollars and it was Akai and
Roger Linn's elaboration on the Linn drum
machine. The concept though of taking
samples of prerecorded sound and
composing with them existed long before
the late 1980s, but those machines were
limited by their price and portability.
The MPC was a different beast because it
really put you in the driver's seat in
terms of a sonic texture that you
wanted to have. That's Brian "Raydar" Ellis,
and that's his MPC Renaissance. You know
really just make a mess of it.
It's a fully customizable machine where
as you look at maybe like the Linn drum
or the Roland tr-808 which were
specifically drum machines, the sounds
came pre-loaded and you couldn't change
them. In short, the MPC 60 was the
musical brain of the studio. By 1994 when
Akai introduced the MPC 3000 it was the
tool of choice for many of the top
hip-hop producers in the game including,
J Dilla.
I think the thing with Dilla that
inspired so many producers is that he
was able to use such a wide vocabulary
of technique. J Dilla was a producer out
of Detroit in the mid-90s through his
early death in 2006 from a rare blood
disease. He passed away just three days
after releasing one of his most
fascinating and beloved albums, Donuts. He
worked with an astounding list of iconic
artists and pulled off the majority of
his sound with just a few simple
instruments, machines, and digital samplers, one of
them being the MPC. He knew how to get
into every piece of the MPC and use it
to a musical advantage. So let's talk
about J Dilla's drum style first. He
figured out how to humanize the drum
machine by avoiding certain things that
he could have done to make it more
robotic, make it more stiff. For instance
the MPC has this incredibly useful tool
called quantization. What quantizing does
is it takes your performance, let's say
I'm playing my drum pattern, and when I'm
playing it, sometimes it's a little ahead
it's a little bit time. If your kick
drums are off by a little bit,
quantization snaps them in place. And so
a lot of producers they use quantize, not
as a crutch, but just they just weren't
thinking about not using it and so Dilla was like yeah I'm just gonna turn this
off. The result is a discography full of
incredibly off-kilter drums.
This loose strumming style was
incredibly influential. When Red Bull
Music Academy interviewed Questlove he
said J Dilla's drumming technique
single-handedly changed how he played.
Whereas this part is normal sounding. It sounded like
the kick drum was played by like a drunk
three-year-old. I was like "are you
allowed to do that?" So like that to
me was the most liberating moment. Dilla
was known for his signature low-end
texture and his drums accounted for a
lot of that sound. Here's just a regular
sampled kick, here's what that same kick
with the high-end cutout sounds like.
You'll hear that kick in a lot of Dilla
beats, like on The Pharcyde's "Runnin".
The other half of Dilla's Low end came
from his bass lines. He had a way of kind
of getting the fuzz in the pump out of a
bass line.
The MPC gave Dilla the flexibility to
create and manipulate his bass in a lot
of different ways. J Dilla didn't just
you know drop out of nowhere and just
know how to do everything all at once, he
was listening to a lot of the the
legends. In fact, producers like Large
Professor, they used this technique a lot
to get extra mileage out of the sample.
So right now I got this loop this is Gap
Mangione "Diana in the Autumn Wind."
In order to get a verse section what
producers would do is they would filter
out the high-end and they just leave
this base space in here for the rapper
to rap and then when the chorus came
back around they bring all the
frequencies back, so you have a verse
section and of course section
two-for-one sale.
One of my favorite Dilla baselines
though actually came from his moog
synthesizer which was custom made by
Robert Moog himself. Just focus on how
much his bass line rattles the low end
of the song and meanders in and around
the beat. He's very meticulous about you
know what was going to kind of ooze and
lay back a little bit. You listen to his Moog bass and it couldn't care less if it got
there on time, but somehow it does. He
internalized every possible technique
used in hip hop and expanded upon it, and
he did so with just an intense love and
curiosity of sounds, and a lot of
patience. If we look back at E=MC2
we've got an incredible sub
bass-y low end and example from an
incredibly off-the-wall song by Giorgio
Moroder. Something that that makes this
record stand out is the "equals" how he
extended it, because if you just listen
it kind of only goes for a few beats,
and he was able to extend it as far as
he wanted.
There are so many songs that showed J
Dilla's ability to flip a sample, but
there's one that gives me goosebumps
every time I hear it.
A lot of people think sampling is easy
because they're like oh they're just
listening to the melody on top and
they're not thinking about what the
instruments below that lead melody are
doing and how they're playing a role in
the beat. The first 40 seconds of "Don't
Cry" is just a few long loops of The
Escorts "I can't stand (to see you cry)" -
he barely did anything with them. He's
basically saying "this is all I have to
work with"
at 40 seconds though he says "now look
what I can do with this MPC."
Instead of chopping to the melody, he
chopped up a handful of kicks and snares
throughout the entire song regardless of
the melody on top of it, and like little
puzzle pieces,
he resequenced those kicks and snares to
create this entirely new dreamlike song.
I think Dilla was just like super funky
a lot of that had to do with you know
him being willing to not care if the
record speeds up or slows down as long
as it feels good you know and just
throwing that care out the window and
just being like "forget quantize man, it
does what I say it does" and just rocking like that.
Akai has
released a steady stream of MPC since
the MPC 60 and 3000, they've gotten
glassier, more high-tech, more portable,
and more integrated into digital audio
workstations than ever before. But those
16 pads and scroll knob have persisted,
and that tactile design has even
influenced the design of countless other
pieces of audio software. In the
instruction manual for the MPC 3000,
Roger Linn gives an introduction, and in
that introduction he asks the people
that use the MPC to treat it like an
instrument - it's like the modern-day
piano or violin. And even though a lot of
people say J Dilla never read the manual
for the MPC 3000, he still internalized
that same idea. He used his MPC like Jimi
Hendrix played his guitar, or John
Coltrane played the saxophone - it was an
extension of himself.
That's probably why out of all the MPC's
used by countless hip-hop producers and
beat makers
over the years, J Dilla's is in a museum.
Hey thanks so much for watching the
video, I want to give a special thanks to
Brian "Raydar" Ellis. In addition to being a
professor at Berkeley, he is also an emcee and
producer and I've linked his work below
in the description. You will also find
all of my sources and a lot of amazing
links to further reading about J Dilla
if you want to learn more about him. I
didn't make a Spotify playlist and
that's because one of the greatest ones
about J Dilla already exists. I've linked
to that one in the description below
it's like 16 hours long it's amazing.